Learn how to create a custom blog with HTML
and CSS in this full course from Julio codes.
What is going on everybody? My name is Julio in
in today's lesson, you will build a responsive
website from scratch. Before I give you an
overview of the project, I want to thank
recode combat org for Lendy media platform and
allow me to share my knowledge with you today.
Now let's take a look at the project that you
will build. First, let's go over the header.
The header section holds the navigation and all of
its items. Here we have the theme toggle button.
This button will transition the color scheme into
the light theme. We will use JavaScript to store
the theme selection within local storage.
This means that your theme selection will
remain active even if you close the page or
the browser. Then we have the Search button.
When clicked, a pop up will be activated in the
search bar it will show you have two options for
closing the pop up, you can either click on the
Close icon or hit the Escape key on your keyboard.
Moving on, we have a sign in and
sign up button. These buttons
do not lead anywhere. But if you
wanted to build upon this project,
you could create pages with these buttons. Also,
we have a cool hover effect on the signup button
where some of you this might look familiar.
In fact, the entire dark theme might look
familiar. And this is because I use code
pen AIOs its color scheme for inspiration.
Then we have the main section. This section will
be a grid that is split into two sides. Here we
will have nested grids as well. On the left, we
will utilize grid to position the items in a way
that will allow us to create a really nice looking
layout. Then on the right side, we have a sidebar.
If we come down here we have the quick read
section, we will utilize a JavaScript library
called Swiper. To create a responsive carousel
Swiper has many functionalities. However, we will
only be taking a look at responsive breakpoints,
and how to make the arrows in pagination work.
Then we have the older posts section. This
section is composed of six cards, though,
you could show as many as you wanted. So is
the bottom you have the See More button. And
this button would allow you to either show
more posts or navigate to a specific page.
The next section is for the popular tags. This
section is composed of six cards. Ideally,
when clicking any of the cards, it would
take you to a page where you would see
posts specifically for this category. Then
we move down to the newsletter section. Here
we have a call to action, prompting users to
subscribe to the newsletter if they wanted to.
Then the last section will be a modern looking
footer. I also wanted to show you the second page,
the blog posts page because aside from the
landing page, it would only make sense that
we also build a blog post page to access this
page. Let's go back up to the first section.
Then we can click either of these three main
cards. Although the page for the post is basic,
you have a lot of room here for making
this page more complex if you want it to
let's go ahead and take a
look at the responsive view.
Let's start with the navigation. Then let's
scroll down and take a look at the rest of
the layout and how it changes and yet
just with the width of the viewport.
Lastly, I wanted to point out that
I have a YouTube channel of my own.
If you enjoy this type of content, be sure to give
me a follow. Without any further ado, let's begin.
Let's quickly go over the files
that you're going to be getting.
So if you go to the link listed
in the description of this video,
you're going to be able to download the completed
files as well as the starter files. I decided to
include the completed files just in case we run
into issues. And this way you can just compare the
code. Now I'll just close this and then go inside
of the starter files. So if you plan on following
along, make sure that you pause the video and grab
the assets and once you're ready, let's begin.
Let's begin by going over what we have here
within the index html So this is just the basic
html5 template. Here, we link to the fav icon,
which is this little icon that we have here.
Then down here, we link to the remix icons,
which is the icons that we are going to be using.
Then we link to the Swiper. J. S CSS
file. And then we link to work on CSS.
Inside of the body here, we just have several
comments for each individual section. And then
we do the same thing down here, instead of linking
to the CSS, we just link to the JavaScript files.
So the first thing that we're going to do here is
go inside of the header. Actually, let me open up
this project with live server first, just so
that we can see the changes as they happen.
I'm also going to keep the completed project here
opened, just so that we can use it as a reference.
So first, let's tackle the header. And inside of
the header, we just have the navigation and all
of its items. So we're going to use the header
element, then we will apply a class of header
as well as an ID of header, the ID, I'm only going
to be using it so that I can select this element,
as well as other elements through JavaScript, you
can do this with the class and even the tag name.
However, I opted out to use the IDS instead for
this purpose. Instead of the header, I'm going
to use the nav element, I'm going to apply the
class of nav bar, as well as a class of container.
The container class will limit how wide a
particular element is going to stretch to inside
of the nav, I'm going to have a logo, so I'll use
an anchor tag, I will point this back to the index
html. And then inside of it, I'm going to have
an h2 that will have the class of logo and the
name of the website. Then I'm going to have a div
with a class of menu, as well as the ID of menu.
Inside of this div, I'm going to have a UL with
a class of list. And then inside of it, an LI
with a class of list item. And then inside of the
list item, an anchor tag with the class of List
link. So now that we have the base for the
list items, all I have to do is just copy this
and paste it down below as many times as we
need. So we're just going to set up a few for
now and then we'll add the rest later. Also, the
main reason why I'm wrapping this list inside of
this menu is because it's going to make the reset
when we transition from mobile to larger screens
a lot simpler. So for the first one, we also
want to add an additional class of current,
since it will be highlighted in this
will be home. Then we have categories.
Then we have reviews, news, membership,
contact. And then here we have the Sign
In link. And we need one more or sign up.
I also want to add an additional class
here, this class will be screen LG hidden.
And I'm going to apply this class to the sign
up button as well. So the main reason is because
these are the links that will show up within
the mobile navigation that you see right here.
So these are normal links. And then when we get
to the larger screens, we hide them from here,
and then we show the fancy ones instead. So let's
go back here, make this smaller. And I'm probably
going to give myself some more space. So I'm
going to close this sidebar here by using Ctrl V,
just like so. Now something else that I want
to do is I want to now exit this menu div,
and underneath, I'm going to add the
rest of the buttons that we have here.
So to do so let's find the closing tag for this
menu div. And underneath, we are going to have
another div. This one will have the class of
list as well, because I want to share some of
the styles without having to override the existing
styles for this link for this list, I should say.
So that's why I'm also going to give this the
class of list right and in here we are just
going to have a lot of buttons. So we're going
to start by using the button element. And we
will apply the class of btn a class of place items
center and then an ID of theme toggle between In
and inside of here, we will have two icons.
So the first icon will have the class of awry
Sun line, then I'm going to add a secondary
class just so that I can manipulate this element
by using this secondary class. So
I'm going to call this sun icon.
Then we're going to duplicate this down below,
and we are going to edit it. So for this one,
we can say Moon icon. And then we can change
sun to moon as well. And if we go back to the
original project here, you'll see that the button
is now visible, and we have the two icons that we
want. Later on, we are going to hide one of these
icons so that only one is visible at a time.
So now that we have the base for the buttons,
what I'll do is go ahead and copy this. Again,
let's just be a little bit lazy here. And then I'm
going to modify this element to fit our need. And
for this one, we will have the search icon. So
this can remain the same. The only difference
here is that we're going to get rid of this ID.
So instead of this ID, we're going to use search
icon, just like so. Or we could even do
search icon btn, it doesn't really matter.
Then in here, we can go ahead and get rid of one
of the icons, since we only need one. And then we
can go ahead and change the class. So this one
is going to be Ri search line, just like so.
And now we get the other button. So we need
one more here. And this button is
going to let me actually copy it again.
Then I'm going to paste it below here. And here,
we're going to have to make some changes as well.
So for this particular button, I'm also
going to add a class here of screen,
LG hidden, because I don't want to see
this particular button on larger screens.
Since the menu is going to be fully visible. I'm
also going to add a class here of menu Hoggle.
icon. And then for the ID, we can just go ahead
and change this as well to menu toggle icon.
We will also have two icons in here. One
is going to be for the hamburger menu,
and the other one is going to be for the x. So
here, we can just go ahead and modify the classes.
This one for the hamburger menu, we'll have
the class of arrived menu and then three line.
And that's already going to show up there, then
we need an additional class called Open Menu icon.
Then what we can do is copy this and replace the
one below it and then make changes here. So we can
change this one to close. And then we can get rid
of three and make it so that it says close line.
And then here we can change open to close, just
like so. Finally, we need the other two buttons.
So that would be the ones we have here that we
are going to show within the larger screens.
And to do that we are going to
be using enter tags. Instead,
the anchor tag is going to have a class of
List link. Again, because I want to share
the same styles that the list links have. Then
I'm going to have an additional class of screen
as some hidden and this is going to do
the opposite, which is just going to hide
this particular item on smaller screens.
And then here we can say sign in
and then copy this underneath. And
here we want to add an additional class
of btn and then sign up BTN. And we'll also
add a class here of fancy border just like so.
And inside of here, we are going to copy the text,
then remove it and then place a span inside of it
followed by the text. And this is going
to be pretty much it for the navigation.
So the next step would be to go inside of the
CSS file so that we can make this look a lot
better. So let's go inside of the assets, CSS and
then main dot css Here, it's going to be the same
deal. We have several comments for each individual
section. And then I'm importing the Google Font of
Poppins that we're going to be using. So let's
go ahead and initialize some custom properties
inside of the root pseudo class. And this just
means that any variable that I initialize in
here is going to be available for use within the
CSS file. So think of it as global scoping. As far
as the naming convention, you want to start with
two hyphens, and then the name of the variable. So
I'm going to call this one light color, just
like so. And then we simply store the value
of the color that we want. We will have another
one, this one will be the light color, Alt,
and then they will have the following hex of a FB,
six C, D, then we will have another one down here.
And this one is going to be for
the primary background color.
And it's going to have the following
revalue. So this one is going to be 1314,
and then 17. And that's pretty much how it goes.
But let me just demo quickly. Something like
for example, if you wanted to store a font, in
this situation, let's say that this is the font
family variable that I want to create. And then
I just simply do the same thing that I normally
would and store the value of Poppins. And that's
pretty much all there is to it. Now, I don't want
to bore you by having you watch me type every
single one of them. So I'm just going to speed
up the process. And then I'm going to include
all the imports, as well as the custom properties
within the starter files, just to make it easier
for you to follow along. So I'll be right back.
Alright, so now that the custom properties are
set, let's go ahead and apply some base styles.
In here, what I like to do is that I
start by using the universal selector,
then I go ahead and I apply a margin of zero,
a padding of zero, and then the box sizing,
I set it to border box. And this just
makes it so that the math when sizing
your elements is going to be a lot simpler,
since everything such as borders, and paddings
is going to be calculated on the inside of
the element as opposed to the outside of it.
Then I'm going to select the HTML document.
And I'm going to set a font size of 10 pixels.
And the reason why I do this is because I prefer
using REM units, as you can see from here,
and this is just going to be a lot better for
responsive design. And by making it 10 pixels
is just going to make the math a lot simpler.
So for example, if I wanted to do 16 pixels,
it's as simple as just doing 1.6 Ram. So that's
what I mean. That being said, I also want to do
B font size in percentages, instead, the recent
being because it's going to scale a lot better
when we use these zoom that we have here within
the browser. So 10 pixels in percentages is going
to be 62.5%. So I'm just going to comment this
one out and keep it as a reference. Now we are
going to select the body. And in here, what I want
to do is apply the font family plus them property.
So to apply a custom property, all you have
to do is just use var, and then inside of
the parentheses, what you want to do is pass in
the name of the variable that you created. So
in this situation, we will use font family,
because that's the name of the variable,
then, as far as the font size, we will do
the same thing. And you don't actually have
to type in var every time at least if you're
using Visual Studio code. So in this case,
all you have to do is just type in the name
of the variable itself. So for example,
I can type in font and you see that we already
get some suggestions. I'm going to be using
the SM font size here. So if I just hit enter or
select it, you see that it already does it for us.
Then as far as the color, this one
is going to be the light color out
and then the background color is going
to be the primary background color.
Then here I'm going to set a letter spacing
of one pixel followed by a transition
which is going to be on the background
color. And it will be over point 25 seconds.
I also want to transition the color over point
25 seconds as well. And this decision is only
there for when we toggle between the themes
so that we get done really nice animation.
Then I'm going to select all of the anchor tags.
And I'm going to get rid of the text decoration
by saying none, then I'm going to set the color
to be inherited from its parent. I'm going to
select all of my images. And I'm going to give
them a max width of 100%. This is going to make
it so that the images will not overflow their
parent container, and then a display of block.
I'm going to select all of my URLs. And I'm just
going to do a list style of none. I'm going to
select my inputs, as well as my buttons. And the
font here is going to be inherited. So if we hover
over and this should be button, not buttons. So
if we hover over the the property here, it just
tells us that it's a shorthand for font style,
font variant font weight, font size, and so on.
Then, what I want to do here is apply a color that
is going to be inherited from its parent as well,
then the border will be set to none, then the
background color is going to be transparent.
And I'm also going to get rid of the outline here.
Finally, I'm going to select all of my tags.
And in here, I just want to set a font size,
which is going to be MD. So font size, MD,
just excel. And now we can go ahead and add
the colors for the light theme. So what we're
basically just going to do is invert some of the
variables that we have right here. And that's
going to take care of everything else for us.
So here, what I want to do is select the body and
say that one, the body has the light theme class.
I want the following styles
to have the following values.
And we are going to start with the light
color. And in fact, it's going to be a
lot easier if I just copy it. So we need primary
secondary. So let me just grab all these for now.
And we'll paste them here. Then
we also need the hover light color
and we will need the transparent
dark and transparent light colors.
So now we can go ahead and change the values.
So this one here is going to have the following
which is 3d. And then for the light color, alt,
this one is going to be switched to a
transparent color. So this is going to be RGBA.
And then we want a black color. So we do
000. And then for the alpha or transparency,
we do point six. For the primary background
color, we're going to be switching this to white.
And then for the secondary background color,
this is going to be a lighter shade of gray.
So this one will be f1 f1 f1. Then for the hovered
light color, what we want to do here is just set
this to white, as well. And for the transparent
dark color, we want to set this one to a solid,
so we will use the color of the secondary
background color that we have right here.
Just like so. Finally, the
last one will stay the same,
except that we are going to make the transparency
a lot more. So we'll just do point one there.
Let's now set up the reusable classes. And we
will start by using the class of container.
And as I mentioned, this is going to limit how
wide a certain element is going to stretch do so
I'm going to make this 160 REM. Then when we have
enough space, I also want to center this container
in the middle. So I'm going to be using a margin
top and bottom of zero and auto left and right.
And then I'm going to create some spacing on the
sides by giving it a padding C row top and bottom
and 1.5 left and right. I'm going to
target the place items center column
And in here, I'm going to be using
Flexbox. This is going to be inline flex,
then I want to align items to the center
and justify content, the center as well.
And there's still a few more things in
here that we will target. But we won't do
that till later on. So for now, let's just
stick to the classes that we have defined.
So in this case, I'm going to select the screen at
some hidden, and this is going to have a display
set to None, simply because we are
starting mobile first. And by default,
we don't want to see anything with this class.
So now let's go ahead and work on the header.
Let's select the header element. And then
here we are going to apply a background color,
which is going to be the secondary background
color, then the position is going to be fixed.
What we want to do next is give it
a starting top position of zero.
And we will do the same for the left,
then we will give this a width of 100%.
Because since we made it fixed in our last its
width. And then finally, we will give it a sea
index of a high value just so that we make
sure that it stays on top of all the content.
Now I'm going to target the nav bar in here,
I'm going to set the display to be a flex,
I want to align my items to the center. And then
I want to justify my content to space between.
And that's going to give us some
separation here between the items
just like you can see there. So let me just bring
this back. And I also want to add some spacing on
the top and bottom. So for that, I'm going to
be using padding, and we can do a padding block
of 1.5. Rem as well. Then I'm going to select the
logo. And the logo is going to have the font size
of font size MD and the color is going to
be white, so we will use the light color.
I will now select the menu. And I'm going
to give this a position of absolute.
The starting top position, I want to position it
under the header. So this is going to be 8.5. REM.
But the right, I'm going to do the same
spacing that I had with the container just
so that it lines up. And then I'm going to do
a width of 23 Run. Then a padding all around
and a background color, which is going
to be the secondary background color.
And here we want to set the opacity to zero.
However, opacity only hides the element from you.
If I hover over it, you can see that everything's
still clickable, which means it's still there.
So what we want to do next is transform scale. And
we set that to zero, and it's going to shrink it
all the way down. So it's no longer clickable.
And obviously, we want to still see the menu
since we're working on it. This is going to
be for JavaScript purposes later on when we
hide it and show it. So for the time
being, let's go ahead and comment that out.
Then we want a transition here, which is going to
be for the same purpose of showing and hiding the
menu on the opacity over point 25 seconds
ease and now I'm going to select the list
and the list is going to have a display of flex.
Then I want to align my items to the center as
well. And I want to set some spacing, so I'll
use the gap here as well. And even though it's
not looking quite right, the solution to fix
this is by applying a flex direction of column.
However, I don't want to do this here,
because remember that we have multiple lists.
So if I applied it to this list, then it means
that it's going to apply it to every single
element that has the same class. And that's not
what we want. So let's go ahead and remove this.
And instead, I'll specifically apply
it to the element that I want to
in this case, it's going to be the list
that is a direct child of the menu element.
Just like so. And if we go back to the HTML
document, here you can see that this list is a
direct child of this menu element. So what I want
to do next is select the list link that is current
So for this, we just make sure that
we chain the two classes together.
And here, what we want to do is change the color.
So the color here is going to be the light color.
So now what's different, well, slightly
different from the rest of them.
Next, I'm going to remove the clothes
menu icon, which is going to be the x.
So let's select the clothes menu
icon and give this a display of none.
Now I'm going to select all the VT ns. And
what I want to do here is set the cursor
to be a foreigner so that when we hover
over the buttons, we get the appearance
that it's clickable. I know when to set some hover
effects. So I'm going to select the list link.
On hover, and the following styles are going to
be applied. So this is just going to be a change
of color, which is going to be transitioning to
the light color, custom property that we have.
So if we go ahead and try that
out, you can see that it works.
However, we still want to
apply this same effect to
the buttons. And we want to apply it to
the span instead of the buttons as well.
So we'll do btn hover, and
then the span inside of it.
And one more thing that I want to do now
is hide the moon icon, because by default,
we are going to be within the dark theme.
So we only want to see the sun icon.
And we'll just set the
display property here to none.
Now I'm going to select the life
theme, and then the sign icon.
In this is going to have a display of none.
And this just means that when the body has
the light theme class, then the sun icon,
we no longer want to see it, the one that we
do want to see is going to be the moon icon.
So we're going to grab this, and we'll repeat
it for the light theme. And then the moon
icon. And the only difference here is that we
change this one to block so that we show it.
Now, you're not going to be seeing
that in play right now. But you will
later once we get into the JavaScript portion,
which is going to be shortly. But before that,
let's set up the styles that we are going to
trigger once we get to the JavaScript portion.
So that's going to be down here. And the first
thing that I want to do is add a box shadow to
this header once we start scrolling. So let's
target the header. And then we'll say that
when the header is activated, or when it has the
class of activated, we want to apply a box shadow,
which is going to have the value of zero for
the X offset, one pixel for the Y offset, and
then point five REM for the blur and spread. And
then it's going to have a transparent light color.
Now we're going to do something similar
here for the menu. So let's just copy that.
And let's change header to menu.
So this is going to be slightly different now
because we are going to have one pixel here for
the X offset as well. And then we'll just change
this to one and the rest can remain the same.
So remember that I said that first we hide
this and then we show it on click. So this
is where it comes into play. So Let's uncomment
that out now. And then we are going to copy it
and we'll paste it down here. Then
we just change the zero to ones
just like so. Then we also want to be able to
switch the icons. So the next thing that I'm
going to do is select the menu toggle icon. And
we are going to say that when it's activated.
Let's remove the menu class from
here because we don't need it.
So when it's activated, we want
to target the Open Menu icon.
And then here we want to set the display to
none Then we'll do the same thing with the exe.
So let's change, open to close. And then this one
will be blocked, because we do want to show it.
So let's go ahead and open up the JavaScript
file. And in here, what I'm going to do is
define a function that is going to allow us to
select elements very easily. And this is going
to work similar to how jQuery does it. By the way,
shout out to John from coding addict, this is the
method that he uses, it's actually pretty useful.
So we'll start by declaring a function expression.
And I'm going to call it select element. And then
in here, we can have a parameter of selector.
You can call this whatever you want.
And it will be an arrow function.
And what we want to do in here
is define another variable,
this one I'm going to call element, and then I'm
going to store the value of whatever we pass in,
into this element variable. So document, query
selector. And now we pass in the selector,
then what we want to do is add in some
validation, so we'll say if element,
meaning whether it's true or false. In this case,
if it's true, we want to return the element.
If not, what we can do is throw an error.
So we'll say throw new error, and then we'll use
the backticks. And in here, we can have a custom
error message. So I'm going to type in something
went wrong. Make sure that the selector
this is going to make sure that it
tells you which selector it is that is
wrong or typed in correctly, based on what we
passed in. So make sure that the selector exists,
or is typed correctly.
Just like so. So now we can go ahead and test that
out. So we'll call the select element function.
And we are going to pass in an
element that we know what is valid,
so in this case, DNF bar. Let's also console log
that. So let's go ahead and open up the console.
And see if we get the element that we want. And
we do so here we have the nav element. Now let's
see what happens if we add in an element
that doesn't exist. So let's say footer.
And now you see that we get the error, something
went wrong, make sure that footer exists, or it's
typed correctly. So now that we know that this
is working, we can get rid of this console log.
And we can move on. So now we
can go ahead and add the styles
that are going to trigger on scroll to the header.
So for this, I'm going to have another function.
I will call this one scroll header. And then
what I'll do is have another arrow function here.
And I'm going to define a variable called
nav bar element. And then I'm going to call the
select element function and pass in the header ID.
And I shouldn't call this one knife bar element,
I should have called that header element. Then,
underneath, what I want to do is have an if
statement to check if the scroll has past a
certain point. And if it does, then we want
to do something in this case, add a class.
And if not, we want to remove that class. So
we'll say if then we will use the this keyword
since this function is going to be attached to the
window object, scroll y. And then we want to check
if it's greater or equal to 15. If it
is, we want to add a class. And if not,
we want to remove that class. So we'll
say header element class list and then add
activated. So let's go ahead and grab that. Paste
it underneath and remove and in add remove and
then we'll scroll to the end here. And we're going
to add a demo element. So I'm going to say search.
And then within the CSS I'm going to select
it and give it a really high height. So sorry
and the height is going to be 2000 Ram.
And now we get the scroll bars. And we can
suss that out. So obviously, it's not working
because we still haven't called the function.
So for that, we are going to attach an
event listener to the window object,
which is going to be of scroll. And then we
just simply pass in this scroll header function.
And now if you go ahead and test that out, you
can see that it shows up, it's really subtle,
so you can't see it all that much. Let me actually
demonstrate by by adding a background color here
of red. So now once we scroll past that
15, you see that we get the background
color of red. And if we go back to the start, it
goes to the normal color. So this is working. So
let's now go ahead and get rid of this as
well as this since we no longer need it.
And then we can move along and keep working
on the rest. So the next thing that I want
to do now is open and close the menu.
So we're going to do that down here.
We're going to start by defining a variable, which
is going to be called menu Hoggle. icon. And then
here, we just call the select element function
again. And we pass in the ID of menu toggle icon.
Then what we want to do is create another
function, which I'm going to call toggle menu.
And this will be another arrow function.
And in here, what I want to do is just toggle
some classes. So mobile, well first, let me define
a variable so that we can store the menu
element inside of it. I'm going to call
this one mobile menu. And then we call the
select element function once more, pass in
the ID of menu. And now we can do something
with it. So mobile menu classlist toggle.
And then what we can do in here is
say that we want to toggle activated.
And then what we want to do is just toggle
the classlist on the menu toggle icon
which is going to be the same one.
Now we're going to call the
function then add event listener.
This one is going to be a click
event. And we go ahead and pass
on the menu toggle function that we created. At
actually, it's the other way around,
toggle menu. So now if we test that out,
it should be in working order. There we go. And
notice how the icons are being switched as well.
Since we're already here, let's go ahead and add
the functionality to switch between the themes.
So let's start by defining a
variable called body element.
And then we can just store the body element
itself, we don't have to call the function here,
we can just simply do body, I mean document dot
body. And that's going to work the same way.
I need to also create one
for the theme toggle BTN.
And then I'm going to call the function
here and store the theme toggle
BTN. And here. Then I'm going to add an event
listener to this theme toggle btn variable
and what we want to do in here is toggle
the class the the life theme class
on the body. So you're going to use the body
element classlist toggle and then light theme.
And this should work now. So if we click it,
you see that the theme changes and the icons
as well. But if I refresh the page, notice
how it disappears. And that's because now we
have to add it into local storage. So that the
theme selection saved. So how do we do that?
Well, as I mentioned, after we click this button,
the body is going to have the class list of
lysine toggled. So what we have to
do now is add some if statements.
So here we are going to say that if the body
element class list contains the class of lysine.
So again, it's saying if the body currently has
the class of lysine, then we want to do something.
And that's something is that we want
to set this theme within local storage.
So we'll select the local storage interface,
and then we'll call the set item method.
And here, we just basically have a key value
pair. And in this situation, the first value
that we pass in, this is going to be the key
name. So let me just call this current theme.
And then, for the name of the value
itself, we can just call this theme active.
And then for the else condition, we just want
to remove this item from local storage if the
class is not present. So we're going to call
this piece down here. And as opposed to seeing
that item, we just say, remove item. And then we
just need the current theme here. But that's not
going to be enough yet. So let's test it out.
If I refresh it, you see that it's still gone.
So what we have to do now is get the item that
is currently stored within local storage. So
for that, let me define another variable up here.
In this one, I'm going to call it current theme.
And then what we want to do now is get that item
from local storage. So we say local storage.
And then we use the get item method to get
the current theme that we have stored within local
storage. So here, we just pass in the name of the
key that we have here. And what I put this
over here, so here we just say current
theme. Now, again, that alone
is not enough to do anything.
So we have to add in another if statement.
And we're going to be doing this outside.
So here, what we are going to do is say that if
there is a current theme within local storage,
so we can just say current theme. So
if there's a Korean theme present,
we want to make sure that the
body has that life in class.
So again, we will just say body element,
and then plus list. Add light theme.
So let's go ahead and test that out. Well, as
you can see, it's already in local storage,
so it just changed automatically after Visual
Studio, refresh the browser with live server.
So as you can see, the theme selection is
still there. Same thing will happen if we
refreshed on the dark theme. So let's quickly
over again what we did. So we defined a variable
here to store the body element, then we did
the same thing for the theme toggle BTN.
Then here, we just basically get the current
item that we stored within local storage.
Then in this if statement, we check if
there's the current item, so a current
theme and the situation. And if there is the
body element, we'll get the class of life theme,
which is going to trigger the life theme styles.
Here within the event listener, when this
btn is clicked, what will happen is that the
body element is going to have the life theme
added or removed, depending on if you double click
it or not. And again, we check if the body element
has that class and if it does, it's going to
be set within local storage. And if it's not,
it's going to be removed. So that's basically
everything we did there. The next step is going
to be going inside of the index html so that we
can work on the search portion of this project.
So we'll continue here by having a
div with the class of search form.
container as well as the class of container
and the ID of search form container.
Just Excel. Then inside we are going to have a
div with the class of form container in there
and inside of here, we will have the form itself.
So the form is going to have the class of form.
The action can be left empty for now,
since this form is not functional,
and then instead of the form, we will have an
input that will have the class of form input.
This input is going to be of type text, and
it will have a placeholder that will say,
What are you looking for.
Underneath, we are going to have a button
with a class of btn and the class of form BTN.
And this button is going to be of type
submit. Then, as far as the inside,
I'm going to be placing here a icon. And this icon
is going to have the class of Ri, and then search
line. Just Excel. So for the time being, we
can't see it, but that's because it's under this.
Then underneath of the form, we are going to have
the text that is going to be for the or press
Escape to close. So that would be this right
here. And this bin is going to have the class
of form note. And then we can
just say or press Escape to close.
So now outside of this form container, enter,
we are going to have another button. This button
is going to have the class of BTN. Form, close btn
the class of place Evidence Center and then the ID
of form, close BTN. Just Excel. And then we'll
just put in the X icon. So we'll do ri, close
line, just excel. So now we can see some of it
underneath. And this is going to be it for the
form. What we are going to do next is go inside
of the main dot css so that we can style it.
And we are going to begin by
selecting the search form container.
This is going to have a width of
100%. The height is going to be
100 of the BH and I'm also going
to set a max width here of 100%.
Then the background color is going
to be the primary background color.
Let me get rid of the spacing there. And
now the position is going to be fixed
up starting position will be zero, left will be
zero as well see index is going to be a really,
really high value because I want
this to be at the top of everything,
then display will be set to flex, then
the opacity here is going to be set to
zero, the Transform Scale is going to be a
set to zero. And then we want to transition
the opacity and it's going to be over point
five seconds. Now the same concept as before.
Let's comment this out for now because we still
need to see what we're doing with this form.
And then we can continue underneath. So now
I'm going to select the warm container, Enter.
And this is going to have a margin of auto and
that's just going to center it in the middle
just like so then this will have a display
of flex, flex direction will be column.
And then I'll add a gap we're spacing and
then I want to text align to the center.
Now I'm going to select the form itself. In
this will just have a display of flex as well.
And then I want to justify my content
to the center to place it in the middle.
Then I'm going to select
the inputs, the form input
as well as the form btn because these
styles, they will have it in common.
Here I'm going to give this a display of
inline block, just so that it respects
the padding and margins on top. Then I'm
going to give this a border of two pixels
solid and then it's going to be the secondary
background color. So now it's taking Sheet,
then I want to make them a little bit larger.
So I'm going to give it a padding all around.
And then the color. Well, I'm already inheriting
the color here, so I don't have to do anything.
The next thing that I'm going to do
is select the form input by itself.
And I want to add the following styles. So
the first one is going to be able to write
which is going to be if none, then
what I want to do is give it a width
of 100%, then the background color is
going to be the primary background color.
Because as it is, it's going to be
transparent. And in this situation,
I guess we could do without having a background
color here, since the parent already has it. So we
can just get rid of this actually. Now, let's like
the form btn, this is going to have a margin left,
which is going to be negative point five
REM, and that's just going to push it a
little bit to the left, then as far as
the border left, we can get rid of it.
Then for the background color here, we can
just set the secondary background color.
And we can do a width of a ramp just
like so. Now as far as the form note,
we can do a font size of extra small.
And then I want to basically align it all the way
to the left. So for that I can just do align self
and then flex and then I'm going
to select the form close BTN.
In here, I'm going to give it a position
of absolute top is going to be 1.5 gram,
the right is going to be 1.5 GB RAM as well,
then the border is going to be two pixels
solid. And then we can just do the
secondary background color here as well.
Then, as far as the width, we can do for RAM,
the height is going to be for RAM as well.
And then what we can do is give this a display
of flex. Although Nevermind, I think we already
took care of that with the place items,
center classes. So we don't need this.
Because I was just going to do a line
items center and justify content center.
But since that class has already
done that for us, we don't need it.
So now we can go ahead and make this functional
meaning by removing and showing this form whenever
we click on the Search icon. And to do so let's
set up the styles for the forum. So what we are
going to do here is say search form container.
And then when it has the class of activated,
we want to set the opacity back
to one and the Transform Scale
back to one as well. So remember, we commented
this out, Let's uncomment it out again.
And now we get the default behavior. So when we
go and set up the JavaScript portion for this,
when we click this button,
the form should show up.
So let's go ahead and do that right now. Let's
scroll all the way down here. And what we are
going to do is set up some variables. So the
first one is going to be for the form open btn
and then we call the select element function
and we pass in the ID of search icon.
Then we're going to duplicate this a couple
more times below. This one is going to be
for the form close btn and the last one is
going to be for the search form container.
Now all we have to do is just switch up the
variables form say search form container stator.
And for this one, we can
just switch open to close.
Then underneath of here, what I'm going to do
is have an event listener that I'm going
to be attaching to the form open BTN.
And this event listener is going to be of click,
then here, we can just have an arrow function.
And since we only have one line, we don't really
need to use the curly braces here. So we can just
straight up say, search form container, class
list, and then add in, what we can do here is
say that we want to add the class of activated.
So if we go ahead and test
that out, now it should work.
So it pops up. If we click it still there, because
we still have to add the other event listener.
So for that, it's going to be very simple, we're
just going to duplicate the other one down below,
then switch, close, open, I should say, switch
open to close. And then as opposed to adding,
we remove. So now if I click, it should open.
And if I click this button, it should be gone.
So the last thing we have to do here is make
this functional by removing the class when we
hit the Escape key. And to do that, what we can
do is add an event listener on the window object.
So we can say window, add event listener, and
this event listener is going to be of key up.
And then we can just have an arrow function here.
And since it's only one parameter, we can
just forget about the parentheses here,
and just do the parameter itself. And in this
case, I'm just going to call this one event.
And I'm missing the parentheses here for the
event listener. And then here, what we want
to do is set up an if statement. And this if
statement is going to check whether the key of
Escape has been pressed. So for that, we can say
event, that key. And then if it's equal to escape,
then we want to do something. In this case, what
we want to do is search form container classlist.
Remove, I guess we could have just copied it
from here, but it's too late already activated.
So let's go ahead and test that out.
So if we click it, it will open.
If we hit the Escape key, it's now closed.
So that's pretty much all there is to this
portion of the JavaScript. The last thing that
we are going to be doing here is for Swiper J S,
but we're not there yet. So we're not going to
worry about it for now. The thing that we do have
to do now is go back inside of the index html so
that we can work on the featured articles section.
So let's select the section element. And
then we can apply a class of featured
articles as well as a class
of Section Header offset.
Inside of here, we will have a div with
the class of featured articles container.
And then another class of container
can get this right, and a third class of the grid.
So the de grid class is going to turn any element
into a grid container. And it's also going
to be another one of our reusable classes.
Then inside of here, I'm
going to have a nested grid.
So this one is going to have the class
of featured content as well as the grid.
So in here, I want to have a div. This div is
going to have the class of headline banner.
And inside of it I'm going
to have the headline itself.
So this is going to be an h3 that has the class
of headline and the class of fancy border.
Inside of it, we will have a span and the span
is going to have the class of place items center
and then for the text it will be breaking news.
Underneath we are going to have another span
this one with the class of headline Description.
And then we can say Apple
announces a new partnership.
Underneath of the headline banner, we are
going to have all of the cards. So for this,
we will use an anchor tag, this anchor
tag is going to have a class of Article,
then it will have the class of featured article
and then an additional class a featured article.
One, then we can just link to the post page,
and then we can move on. So, inside of here,
I'm going to have an image, this image is
going to have the class of Article image.
And the image that I want to use is
going to be inside the assets folder,
images folder, the featured folder,
and then featured one. Under the image,
I'm going to have a span and the span is
going to have the class of Article category.
And for the text here, we can just use anything.
So underneath of the span, I'm
going to have another wrapper div,
and this one is going to have the
class of Article data container.
Inside of it, I'm going to have another div,
this one is going to be for the article data.
And I'll have three spans in here. So what
I want to do is add some text in here.
And then for the middle one, we
can add a class of Article data
spacer and then the last one will be the estimated
retime. Finally, underneath, we are going to have
an h3 and this h3 is going to have the class
of title as well as the class of Article Title
SBR the future
and that's going to be the base
where every single card that we have.
So let's go ahead and copy this
one. And we can paste it underneath
three more times. Well two more times
since we only have three of them.
And now we can just go ahead and change the
data. So for this one, we can change the image
to number two, as well as the featured article to
number two. And then the last one will be three.
Just like so. So now I'm debating whether
I should go inside of the CSS and make this
portion look better. Or if I should add in
the rest, which is going to be the sidebar.
So for now, I'm guessing that I can just go ahead
and just do the CSS for this portion. And then I
can come back once I do that. So let's go inside
of the CSS now. And let's make this look better.
So let's go all the way back up to the
reusable classes. And what I'm going to do here
is find the reusable classes comment and
I'm going to add in the D word class.
Then I'm also going to add a class for
the sections which we still haven't used.
And I'm going to add padding top and bottom
here. So I'm just going to use the padding block
instead. I was going to do this later but might
as well just do it now and get it out of the way.
So now here, what we want to do
is select the featured articles.
And I'm going to give this a padding block
of two REM then I'm going to
select the section header offset.
And this is going to have a margin top
of 7.4 ramp and that's going to push
the content down underneath of the header.
The next thing that I want to do is select
the featured articles container as well as the
Featured Content since they both share same gap.
Underneath, I'm going to
select the headline banner
in this will have a background color of
secondary background color display will be flex
align items will be center. And then to
create some separation between the two texts,
I'm going to also give this a gap. And then
the font size is going to be extra small.
Now I'm going to select the headline by
itself. And this is going to have a color
which is going to be the light color. Then
I'm going to give this a font size of one REM
texture textures form of uppercase, and
then text align is going to be center,
then I'm going to give it some padding
of point four rem and the height of 100%.
I'm now going to select the headline span.
And this is going to have
the height that is inherited.
And I'm giving this a position of relative
as well as the overflow of hidden.
Then underneath, I'm going to select the
fancy border once more. And I'm going to
create a pseudo element. So we have to add in the
content, which is going to be an empty string.
If we don't add this, then the
element is not going to show up.
Then the position of absolute up starting position
zero, same thing for the left, and then the width
is going to be double. So I'm going to do 200%
Just so that this element is twice as large,
then the height is going to be 100% then the
background is going to be the gradient color.
Then the background size will be 50% 100%.
So now we get a nicer layout here for the
background colors, then I'm going to give
this a C index which is going to be five.
And then underneath, I'm going to select the
fancy border span. And this is going to have
a position of relative because I want to add
is the index of 10 so that it sends the text
to the top of the background. Then this
is going to get a display of inline block.
Actually, I'm going to do display, inline
flex. And then I'm going to set a padding,
which is going to be point six, top
and bottom 1.5 Left and Right. Finally,
I'm going to give this a background color, which
is going to be the secondary background color.
No don't mind too much that it looks squished
up there. The reason why it looks like that
is because I'm zooming in 150% I made the
smaller you see that it looks just fine.
So the next thing that I'm going
to do now is select the article
title. Actually, before I select the
article title, let me actually style the
article itself. So the article here is
going to have the position or relative.
Since I'm going to have some elements that
will have position absolute inside of it.
Then I'm going to set a min height. So this is the
minimum height that each item is going to have.
And for that we will use the variable of
item in height and D. Then I'm going to
select the article image. And this
we'll have a position of absolute.
Then I'm going to give this a width of 100%.
The height of 100% as well. And then we can
do object fit of cover just so that the image
is going to scale a lot better within its box.
Then I'm going to do a transition on the transform
over point 25 seconds. And this is going to be
for the hover effect where the image is zoomed in
when we hover over it this not this isn't going to
take effect now but it will later down the line.
So the next thing that I want to
target is the article category
and this will help The position of
absolute top is going to be one ram.
Right, one ram as well, then padding
all around will also be one ram,
one size, one ram. And then the background color
is going to be the primary background color.
Next, I'm going to set the color of light. And
I'm going to also set a text transform uppercase,
followed by C index of 10. The next thing that
I'm going to style is the article data container.
And this will have a position of
absolute as well, because we are
going to be positioning it to the bottom, and
then the bottom is going to be set to zero,
left zero as well. padding is
going to be to ram top and bottom
1.5 Ram left and right. The background color is
going to be the transparent background color.
And this should be dark color, not the light one.
And then you see index here as well of 10 just
so that it stays on top of the other content. Now
since we have the position of absolute here, it's
only taking up as much space as it needs. So let's
make sure that we also give this a width of 100%.
Just Excel, we also want to add a hover
effect here. So let's add a transition
so that the hover is animated. And
this will be on the background color.
And it will be over point five seconds. Just
Excel. So the next thing that I'm going to
do is add the hover effects themselves.
So I'm going to select the article. And
I'll say that when the article is hovered,
I want to target the article data container.
So the background color here is now going to be
the hover background color for the dark color.
And then the color itself is
going to be hover light color.
So if we go ahead and try that
out, you'll see that we now get the
solid background color here. Now,
let's target the article data.
And what we want to do here is
give this a display of flex.
And then we want to align items to the center.
Then we will apply a gap for separation.
And then we are going to apply a font
size which is going to be extra small.
Finally, I'm going to add a margin bottom for
additional separation between this text and the
title. And it's going to be one REM just excel.
Now we are going to generate the article spacer
and this will have a width of point by
REM eight of point five REM as well.
Then the background color is
going to be the light color alt.
And finally, what we want to do is rotate
it by 45 degrees. So transform, rotate
45 degrees. And that's now going to look more like
a little diamond. And the next thing that I want
to target now is going to be well as you can see
the hover effect is not applying to this element.
So what we have to do is come back
here then we can get rid of this.
We can switch this over to well I get rid
of the curly brace there for no reason.
But now we switch dark to light and we switch this
to the spacer class. And now if you hover over it,
it should work and it does. So let's go
back down and let's now style the title.
The title is going to have
the color of light color
and now you see the difference between this
text and the title when it's not being hovered.
And one last thing is going
to be the article title itself
and this is just going to have a font size of MD
Just like so. So next we are going to work
on the sidebar. But before we actually do
anything with the CSS, what we have to
do is jump back inside of the index html,
so that we can write the markup for it. So let
me make a comment here. Sidebar. And under here,
we are going to start by having a div with
the class of sidebar as well as the grid.
And then inside of it, we will have an h three,
this h three is going to have the class of title
and featured content title trending news
and should only be trending then here we are
going to have the card itself. For this we
will use an anchor tag again with the class of
trending news box. So we can use a placeholder
there. And then inside of it, we will have a
div with a class of trending news image box
inside of here, we will have a span
that has the class of trending number,
we will have an additional class of place
items center and then this is going to be 01
Then we will have the image that
will have a class of particle image.
We can go inside of the
assets folder, images folder,
and then trending. And it's going to be the first
image underneath of the trending news image box,
we are going to have another div and this div
is going to have a class of trending news data.
And we already have the base for this article
data since we are going to repeat it. So let's
just copy that. And we can paste it in here.
Then underneath we are going to have an h3 and
this h3 is going to have the class of
title as well as the class of Article.
Title. We already had this as well.
So I guess we could have copied it but
kind of late now. Then we can just do sample
article, title, just excel. And again, this
is the base for each individual card that we are
going to have. So we can just copy the anchor tag.
And then we can just paste it underneath as many
times as we need. So in this case, we had five
and that should be the last one. So now we can
just go ahead and change the images or three,
and two, because we already have one and number
one. Let's also go ahead and change the text
and this is going to be number four,
and finally, number five, so that's going to be
it for each individual card that we are going
to have inside of the sidebar. So it's going
to be the same deal. Now what we have to do
is go inside of the CSS so that we can style
it. So let's go ahead and select the sidebar.
This will have a background color, which is
going to be the secondary background color
padding all around of 2.5 REM. Then underneath,
I'm going to select the training news box.
This will have a display of flex flex direction
column and then the gap for separation.
And underneath I'm also going to add some
padding top and bottom so I'm going to do
padding block of two REM then finally I'm going to
add a border which is going to be one pixel solid
and then it's going to be
the transparent light color.
And now I'm going to select the trending news
box which is the last one so trending news box,
last of type and what we are going to do is that
we are going to To get rid of this border bottom,
so border bottom, none. And I know you
can't see it right now. But that's because
we haven't added the position of relative to this
image box that we have here. But we're going to
be taking care of that right now. So trending
news image box. Now you'll see that the moment
I give it the position or relative, it's going
to fix itself. And that's because this image right
here, if you remember correctly, this particular
class, we added the position of absolute. So
it just needed the class of relative so that
this image would be positioned absolute relative
to this div. So if we go back in here, I'm going
to give this a width of 100%, then I'm going to
give it a height. And this height is going to be
the item in height at some. And now I'm going to
go ahead and select the featured content title.
In this will have a font size of MD.
It will also have a text align of center,
and then a padding all around of one REM.
Next, I'm going to select the trending
number. This will have a position of absolute
then the top negative one REM left is
going to be negative one REM as well.
It's the index of 15, then a width of three REM
height is going to be three REM as well. The
background color is going to be the secondary
background color. And then the color
itself is going to be the light color.
What I want to do next is give it a
border radius of 50% to make it round.
Just like so. And the last thing that I'm
going to do here is select the trending news
data article title.
article title, and this is going to have
a font size of SM. I'm also going to add a
hover effect here. So trending news box on
hover, I want to target the article title.
And then the color here is going to be the light
color. Well, first, we have to specify that I'd
say color before we actually use the variable.
So light color. And it's going to be the alt just
like so. So now you see that if we hover over it,
we get the effect that we want. So
let's compare with the original.
As you can see, this one is still slightly
smaller. So let me double check that.
Well, the reason is because this one is a 150%.
The original that I have here for the demo is
that 150% And then the original project is
at 100%. So if we make it the same size,
you see that now they both look pretty similar.
And except for the text right here, because I'm
just doing the same one that I had before from
copying and pasting. Again, text doesn't really
matter that can easily be changed. So now the
next part is going to be working on the quick read
section. So back inside of the index html, what
we are going to do here is layout the markup.
So first, let's begin by having a section
element that will have the class of quick read.
And it will also have the class of section. Inside
of it. I'm going to have the class of container.
And then in here I'm going to have an h2 with a
class of title and then a class of section title.
I'm also going to apply a data attribute
here. So I'm going to call this one data name.
And what I'm going to inside of
here is the name of this elements,
which is going to be the quick read. And then
inside of here, I'm going to have the same thing.
And that's because we have over here the
the title set up this way, where we have a faded
one that is going to be slightly larger in the
back. And for that, we're just going to be using
this data element within the pseudo element.
So maybe I should just bring this
over back, one line, just excel.
And now we can lay out the markup for
the Swiper. So in order to start this,
we are going to have a div that
will have the class of Swiper.
And these are all the Swiper classes. So this is
basically the the structure for a Swiper carousel,
then I'm going to have a div that
will have the class of Swiper wrapper.
Instead of here, I'm going to have each
individual card. So this one is going to
have the class of Article, because we still
want to share those styles of the article.
And then it needs the Swiper class of Swiper.
Slide then inside of here, well, we can just
use a placeholder there. And inside of the anchor
tag, we are going to have an image, this image is
going to have the class of Article image. Then we
can go inside of the assets folder, images folder.
And then we can go inside of the quick
read folder. And we can grab the first
image. Then underneath of this image,
we need another article data container.
And in fact, what we can just do
is going get it from the first one that
we had here. So article data container.
So now we can just speed up the process and
paste it over here, let me just make sure that
everything is correct. So we have the Oracle data
container. Then inside of it, we have the article
data, the spacer, and then the title itself.
So that's going to be our first slide. Let me
just create some separation there. So that's more
readable. So let's go ahead and add another one.
Another one, another one, another one, and
then another one. So now what we have to
do is just go ahead and add the images. So
for the first one, we already have the image
covered with a second one, we have
number two, then we have number three,
number four, number five, and number six.
And that's pretty much going to be the structure
for the slides, what we are going to do now is add
the navigation buttons, which is going to be the
right and left arrows, as well as the pagination
controls. So we actually have to add those
underneath of this div, which is going to be
this Swiper wrapper. And this will have the
class of Swiper button breathing. So again
and this we'll have the class of Swiper.
Button for you. And we also want to add an
additional class here of Swiper controls.
Now the Swiper controls class is my own class
that I will be using to style the arrows.
Then we can just go ahead and duplicate this down
below. And then we can change this one to next.
The last thing that we have
to add as the pagination,
as you can see the icons are already showing up
here. So for the pagination, we have to add a
div that will have the class of Swiper pagination
just like so. So that's going to be it for this
particular section. Now the next step is going
to be going inside of the CSS and we are going
to make this look slightly better and Then we
are going to tackle the JavaScript portion.
So down here, we are going
to select the section title.
And this is going to have the position of
relative, it's going to have the font size,
or font size M D, then a margin
bottom, which is going to be six, REM.
And now I'm going to create these pseudo
elements for it. So section and title.
Before, actually, I'll just use the after, well,
let's just keep before since it's actually behind
it. So as far as the content here, what
we can do is use the attribute and then
data name, just excel. So the font size
here is going to be the font size large.
And then we can text transform to uppercase.
The opacity here is going to be point one, so that
it's faded, and position is going to be absolute.
And then it will be positioned 1.4 1.5 Ram, I
should say, from the top, and then from the left
by to ramp. So if we scroll a little bit up,
we should be able to see that right here now.
Then, I'm going to target the
article, and then the swipe or slide.
So we have to do it this way, being more specific
in order to actually override some of the styles
that the Swiper CSS file has. So here, the
height is going to be 40 Ram, just excel. So
the next thing that I'm going to do is add some
additional styles here for the Swiper wrapper.
And the height is going to be
auto, then the Swiper controls.
What I want to do here is give it a width of 3.5.
Rem, I will do the same thing for the height.
And then the background color is going
to be the secondary background color.
Then what I'll do is select
the Swiper controls once more.
And then what I want to do is select the after
pseudo element that Swiper actually creates.
So the font size here is going to be 1.6. Rem, and
that's going to make the controls smaller, or the
arrows I should say. And then for the color, we
are going to make it white as opposed to blue.
So we're going to use the light color. And you
probably noticed that the pagination bullet points
are not showing up. And that's because for them
to show up, we have to first initialize Swiper.
So let's go back inside of the main dot
j s, and the first thing we have to do
here is define a constant variable, which we
are going to call Swiper. And then we have
to create a new instance of Swiper. Then in
here, we can just select the div that we have
with the class of Swiper. And
then we can pass in some options.
So the way it works is by having key value pairs,
so to show a certain amount of slides per view,
in this situation, by default, we have one.
So I'm going to set that here slides per view,
then we set that to the number that we want,
then the next value is going to be for the
spacing that I want between each slide. So
the default spacing that I want is going
to be 20. So for this we use space between
then here we are going to make the arrows
functional. So we have to set the navigation here
and we have to specify the values. So in
this situation for the next el property.
What we want to set is the Swiper class
for a particular button. So this one is
going to be for the next element. So here
we set the Swiper next, actually button next
Then we do the same thing for the Previous button.
So this one, we can change to Prevx. And then we
have to change this one from next to Prevx, as
well. And let's not forget to add a comma here,
and one here as well. Well, this is the
last one, so we don't need it there.
We do need it here, though. So the next thing that
I want to add and make functional is going to be
the pagination. So for that, we say pagination,
and then we just set that to the element that
we have for the pagination. So that's going to be
the div that has the class of Swiper, pagination.
And in here, we just say E L. And then we select
the div with the class of Swiper. Education. And
just like so now, the pagination is showing up.
And this should work already. As you can see,
we can also drag it. So the next thing that I
want to add here is going to be the responsive
breakpoints. So for this, we can just
specify that we want to set breakpoints.
And then here, we can set various different
numbers. So my breakpoints are going to be 700.
And in here, what I want to do
is just show a certain amount
of slides per view. So let me just copy this.
Paste it in here. And I want to show two, then for
the next breakpoint, let me just paste this one
down below. This breakpoint is going to be 1200.
And then I just want to show all three slides.
So if I go ahead and make this bigger now,
you'll notice that it works just fine.
Now we get two, and then we get three.
So that's working exactly how we want it
to work. So one more thing that I have to do is
style, the bullet points here for the pagination.
So let me just minimize this. Put this here to
line it up. And now since we are done with the
whole Swiper JS thing, what we can do is go back
inside of the CSS, and then here we can set the
styles for the bullet points. So I'm going to
start here by selecting the Swiper pagination.
And I'm going to give this a margin bottom.
Well, not a margin bottom, but the bottom position
of point five, REM. And we also have to specify
this as important to override it from the Swiper.
CSS file. Next, I'm going to select the Swiper,
pagination and then bullet. So this is not an
element that we define. It's actually coming
from the Swiper. JS CSS file. And I just noticed
that I misspelled bullet here should be like this.
And here, we just change the
background color to the light color.
And now everything is working
exactly how we want it to work.
So the next step is going to be going back inside
of the index html so that we can work on the older
Post section. So let's scroll down and go inside
of this comment. So this section is going to be
pretty straightforward. Since we are going to
be reusing some of the elements that we already
created before. The only difference is that we
are going to have some slight modifications.
So let's begin by using the section element.
And then let's apply the class of older posts
as well as the class of section. And inside of
here, we are going to have a div with the class
of container. And then followed by the h2 that has
the class of title as well as the class of section
title. Then here we can say older posts. And
let's not forget the data attribute. So data name
older posts. So let's scroll
down. It now shows up here.
And here we are going to have another
container this one is going to have the class
boulder pose, grid wrapper, as well as the class
have the grid and then here this is where we are
going to have each individual card. So again, we
will use an anchor tag with the class of article
as well as a class of D grid, since we also want
to make this particular card, a grid container,
then we can use a placeholder here. And
then inside of it, we are going to have a
div that has the class older posts, article,
image wrapper, I know that was a long one,
then instead of there, we are going to have
an image that has the class of Article image.
And then the image that we want is
going to be inside of the assets folder,
images folder, older pose, and then
it's going to be the first image
underneath, we are going to have the same article
data container that we had before. So let's
actually grab that instead. From here, and the
only difference here is that we are going to have
a p tag that has the class of article description
just like so. And then we can just generate
some dummy text. Let me make that smaller.
Got it about here. And now that we have
the basic structure, we can just go ahead,
copy this anchor tag and paste it down below
five times. Just like so. And now the only
thing we have to do is just change the images.
So this one should be six, this 1543 And two.
So now that we have all the cards
here, with each individual image,
the last thing that we are going to do here is
add in DC more buttons. So underneath of here,
we are going to have a div
that has the class of Seymour
container. Then inside, we will have
an anchor tag that has the class of btn
Seymour btn in place items center, then
this can just be a placeholder and then
see more followed by the icon, which is going to
be the arrow right. So Ri arrow, right S line.
And now we are done with this section. So let's
quickly go inside of the main dot CSS. And let's
make it look better. So let's go ahead and select
the older post grid wrapper. And let's apply
a gap. Then we'll select the older Post article
image wrapper, as well as the older Post
article. Then let's apply a min height, which
is going to be the item and height of SM.
Now I'll select them individually. So all the Post
article, and I will set a background color which
is going to be the secondary background color,
you're not going to see a show through and that's
because the article data container already has
a background color, but we're going to reset
that later. So now I'll select the older Post
article image wrapper, and I'm going to set
the position here to be a relative, then we are
going to apply the reset to the older post read
wrapper, and then the article data container.
So here we just reset the position to static from
absolute. And then here the background color is
going to be transparent. So now the secondary
background color should be showing through. And
that's because we missed that up here. We should
have selected the article data container instead.
So now it works. underneath of that, I'm going
to apply some margin bottom to the article
title that is inside the article. The older post
greater wrapper I should say. So article title.
And this will have the margin bottom of SM
and then down here I'm going to do the same thing
but it's going to be for the Seymour container.
And what I'll do now is scroll
all the way to the bottom.
And then I'm going to give this a margin top
instead, which is going to be the margin MD
and that's going to give us
some additional separation
Next, I'm going to select the Seymour BTN.
And this is going to have
a text transform uppercase,
then I'm going to select the See More button on
hover. And I don't think I do need one though yet,
because I already have it applied globally. So
let's just leave that out. So what I do want
to set Wait, yes, so what I do want to set is the
animation when we hover over it that the arrow is
going to move a little bit to the right. So to do
that, what I have to do is say, see more. And then
the icon, and I want to set a transition
here, which is going to be undie transform.
Over point 25 seconds. And now I
can say that when the Seymour btn
is hovered, I want to target the icon inside
of it. And then I want to transform, Translate
X over point five rent. So let's test that
out. And as you can see, there it works.
So that's going to be it for this particular
section. The next one is going to be the popular
tags. So let's go back inside of the index
html. And let's find the popular tags comment.
So let's go ahead and add the section element,
and then add the class of popular tags.
As well as a class of section. Then inside of it,
we will have a div with the class of container.
And then we will have the
same title that we have been
reusing. So let's just be a little bit lazy
here and copy this portion as well as this one.
Then we'll scroll back to the
bottom. And then we'll paste it in.
And let's close this one off, just like so. So
for this one, we are going to change the class.
And this class is going to be popular tag
or popular tags, I should say container,
and then the D grid class can stay there. Now
as far as this one, we have to rename the data
attribute to popular tags. And then we'll do the
same thing. Well, let's remove the hyphen here
and capitalize the P and then we can just copy
this and paste it in here. So that should work.
Then inside of this container that we have here,
what we are going to do is add an anchor tag with
the class of article. And then inside of it. Well,
we can use a placeholder here and then inside of
it, we can use a span that has the class of tag
name. And then here we can just say travel. Then
underneath, we are going to have an image. This
image is going to have the class of Article image.
And the image is going to be inside
of the assets folder, images folder,
and then tags and then this one
is going to be the travel image.
So that's going to be the basic structure for
every single card that we are going to have
inside of the popular tags. So let's go ahead and
copy this and paste it down below five more times.
Just like so. Well, we need six so we need
one more. So now we can go ahead and just
change the text inside of it as well as the
images. So the second one is going to be food
let me actually capitalize here. So food
do the same here. And then this
one is going to be the food
tag. And I'm not sure if that's what I named it so
let's find out so yet that's going to be the one
then the third one is going to be
technology. Here we'll do the same.
Then we'll do the same for the
fourth one, which is health
then the fifth one is going to be nature
And finally, we have bitness.
So all of our images are now there. Let's go
ahead and go inside of the CSS file now so that
we can make this look better. So in here, what
we will do is target the popular tags container.
We are going to apply a gap for separation,
then we are going to target the
popular text container article.
And what we're going to do here is give this a min
height as well. And this one is going to be a sum.
Then I'm going to select the tag name in this
will have a position of absolute. Then I'm going
to also add a see index here of 10. So that now
the item is going to show up on top of the image.
And then I'm also going to place it
in the middle by using top 50%. Left
50% And then transform translate
negative 50% And then negative
50%. Now I'm going to add a background
color, which is going to be the transparent,
dark color. And that's pretty much all we need
for that. Actually, one more thing that we do
need here is a padding. So the padding is going to
be one REM top and bottom to REM left and right.
Then, what we are going to do is select the
popular tags container, the article inside of it
and we're going to add a hover effect so that when
we hover over it, the tag name is going to change
colors. So popular tags container article on
hover, and then tag name. So here, we want to
change the color to the light color. And if
we test that out, you can see that it works.
Next, I want to add a hover effect to the
image. So again, I'm going to copy this,
paste it down below. And now I'm going
to change this to be the article image.
And should be article image. Just like so.
And then what I do want to change here is the
Transform Scale. And what I want to do is kill it
by 1.05. So if we go ahead and hover over it now,
you can see that it grows. But there's
an issue here because it's overflowing.
So we have to go back to this article right
here and give it an overflow of hidden.
Now if we go ahead and take a look at the hover
effect, and notice how much nicer it looks.
The next section is going to be the newsletter
section. And this one is going to be the
easiest one since we will be reusing a lot of the
styles that we already had for this search form.
So let's begin by using the section
element with the class of newsletter,
as well as a class of section. In here we will
have a div that has the class of container
and then the h2 with the class of
title as well as section title.
This will be newsletter. And let's also add the
data name. So we can just go ahead and copy this
and paste it in here. Scroll down and
now the section title is showing up.
So underneath of here we are going to use a div
that has the class of form container, inner form,
container inner and then in here we are going
to have an h six that has the class of title
as well as the class of newsletter title. And
then we can just say subscribe to news flash.
Then underneath we are going to have a p tag
that has the class of newsletter description
and then we can just generate some dummy text.
Let's make this a lot smaller like so. And
then we are going to have the form itself.
Then we can just repeat what we had before.
So input that has the class of form input
type of text. And then for the
placeholder, we can just use
subscribe. Or let me just check if that's what I
had before. And actually, we had enter your email.
So that's what you're going to
do enter your email address.
Then we had the button. So that's going to be a
button that has the class of BTN. And form BTN.
type will be of submit.
And then we can just use an icon inside
of here, RI mail, and then send line.
Just Excel. And again, notice how we already
have the styles because we're just reusing this
from the previous form. And that's going to
be it for this one, let me just create some
additional spacing here for separation,
just so that the text is more readable.
So let's go ahead and go inside of the CSS so
that we can style the title as well as the text
that we have here. And let's find the comment. And
we're going to start by selecting the newsletter.
And I'm going to give it a padding top actually
not a padding top by padding bottom of six REM.
Then I'm going to select the newsletter title.
And this is going to have the
font size which is going to be LG.
Then I'm going to select
the newsletter Description.
In This will have a margin bottom
should be margin model. And this is going to
be three rem and that's going to give us some
more separation between the text in the form. And
that's pretty much it for this section. The next
section is going to be the footer. So let's go
back inside of the index html. And let's begin.
So we're almost there. The only thing we have left
after this obviously is going to be the CSS for
the footer, and then the blog posts page as well
as the CSS for that page. And then we can finally
move on to the media queries so that we can make
the website responsive and finish the project.
So for the footer, we are going
to be using the footer element.
And we will apply the class of footer as
well as the class of section. And then we
will have a div that has the class of footer
container as well as the class of container.
And then we will have the class of D grid. Since
this one is going to be a grid container as well.
Then in here, I'm going to have a div. This
div is going to have the class of company data.
And then here we are going to have all the data
that you see here. So it's going to have the logo,
a brief description, social media
icons, and then the copyright notice.
So to begin with that, what we
have to do is just add in the logo.
Since we already have the logo here, let's just
go ahead and scroll all the way back to the top
in this just grabbed this then we can go back
inside of the footer and paste it down here.
Then we are going to have a p tag that
has the class of company description.
And then here again, we can just use some dummy
text. So let me just copy what I have here.
Paste it in here. And then we can just go ahead
and add in the social media icons. So for that,
I'm going to have a UL that has the class
of list and the class of social media.
Then we will have an ally that
has the class of list item.
Then we will have the anchor
tag list link. And finally,
inside of here we will have each individual icon
so the first One is going to be for Instagram, Ri,
Instagram, and then the line. So let's go ahead
and take a look at that. Now we see the icon,
then we can just go ahead and copy this
down below as many times as you need.
And now all we have to do is just change the
classes. So for this one, we can do Facebook
Circle Line. And then the third
one is going to be for Twitter.
And the last one is going to be for Pinterest.
And now we have all the icons that we need. So the
last thing that we need here is going to be the
copyright notice. So this is just going to
be a span that has the class of copyright.
Notice, and then we just use ampersand
copy 2021 We're actually in 2022 by now.
And this should be a semicolon. And now that's
just going to generate the little copyright icon.
So next, we can just do
newsflash. All rights reserved.
Then the next thing that I want to do is
have another div. And this is going to be for
the content that we have here. So
we want to group them together.
And we're Wi Fi. So outside
of this company data div,
we want to have another div. And this div is
not going to have any classes. This is only for
the purpose. Since we are using grid here on the
main container, we want to group them together,
just so that the titles here are also together
and not like all spread around this container. So
what we have to do next is inside of here,
we will have an h six that is going to have
a class of title, as well as the class of
footer, title. And then we can just have
any name depending on whatever for the items
you want. This one, I called it categories.
Then underneath, I have another URL. There has
the class of list, as well as the class of footer
list. And the second class of footer list is
just so that I can override some of the styles
that the list has without having to impact
every single list. Then again, Li list item,
anchor tag list link. And then for the text, we
can do anything. In this example, I'll just do the
same text everywhere else. So I'm actually just
going to do a sample item. And now we can just
copy it down below as many times as we need. So
in this situation I'm doing about, let me just do
six. So now that we have the base for every single
item, it's as simple as just copying this one.
And now I'm going to paste it underneath two
more times. So we have a total of three of them.
Just like so. And just to make it a little
different. Let me change the titles. So here
I can say company. And then for this one, what did
I actually call it can't remember. So here we have
company useful links and that's going to be it
for the markup or the footer. So let's go head
back inside of the main dot CSS. And let's style
this up. So the first thing that I'm going to do
is select the footer. The footer
is going to have a background color
which is going to be the secondary background
color. And then the footer container.
In this will have a gap
then as far as the company data, we
want to do a display of flex here
then A flex direction of column to
bring back down. Flex direction.
And the next thing that I want to do in here is
change the order by moving this
data all the way to the bottom.
So we can do order of one. And that's going to
move it down. And I know where you're thinking,
why is it going to the second place if the order
is set to one and not just stay up here? Well,
that's because it starts with zero and not one. So
technically, number zero would be the first one.
Then I'm going to select the company description.
And this we'll have a margin block.
And I'm going to do the margin SM.
Then the max width here that
I'm going to set is going to be
75%. Just to limit how wide
it's going to stretch to
the next thing that I'm going to
select is going to be the social media.
And here I'm going to set a margin bottom
in this one is going to be the margin MD.
Now I'm going to select the copyright notice.
And I'm going to turn the Opacity
down just to make it slightly lighter.
Now I'm going to select the footer list.
And this will have a flex direction of column.
Then I'm going to align items, flex start
just like so. And then I'm going
to select the folder title.
And what I'm going to do here is change the
font size. To me, maybe it'll do font size MD
text transform. Transform
is going to be of uppercase
and then a margin bottom or additional
separation of margin asset. And that's
looking pretty good. Well, we have an issue
here. So that's going to be within the markup.
Let's go ahead and find it. So useful links. It
must have happened when I changed the text here.
So that was the issue right there.
Now everything looks pretty good.
So the next thing that I'm going
to do now is style the scroll bar.
Let me make a comment here,
scroll bar style Stiles.
And what I want to do here is let the scroll bar
so for that we actually have to
use a prefix WebKit scroll bar
and I'm going to change the width to one ram.
Then what I'll do is select the scroll bar track
and then here I'm going to change
the background color to f1 f1 f1.
Then I'm going to select the scroll bar thumb
and this will have a different
color so background and then 34254.
Then I'm going to select the scroll bar thumb when
it's being hovered and add another color to it.
So in fact, we can just copy this, paste that
down here. And now we can just add over to it.
And the color that I'm going to add here is going
to be slightly darker. So two, e three, zero,
and then three, B and as you can see if we hover
over it here, it shows up. Maybe I could do 1.5
To make it slightly bigger. That's actually
fine. So I guess we can just keep that.
Although in the demo, it's smaller. Well, it's
not a big deal. So I guess we can just keep it at
one. And now we can go ahead and work on the blog
post page. So let's open up the sidebar Ctrl B,
and then open up the post dot HTML. So as you can
see here, I'm already including the header markup,
as well as the search, and then the footer,
because this is content that every single
page is going to have in common. So we have
to include it. So if we navigate to the page,
here, you see the header, as well as
the footer, and then everything else
still works the same. So the focus here is
going to be in between this blog post comment,
and the footer comment. This is where all the blog
posts markup is going to go. So let me close this
and everything else that we don't need.
And what we are going to do here is start by
having a section that has the class of blog post,
as well as a class of section, header offset.
And if you remember, this class is going to move
a particular section that is next to the header
down enough so that it's not sitting underneath.
So then what we are going to do here is
have another div and this div is going
to have the class of blog post container.
And let's also apply the container class.
And underneath of this, we
are going to have another div
and this div is going to have
the class of blog post data.
So this is going to be the container for all the
data that we have right here. And then we can just
repeat what we have used to before, which is the
one before that, let's add in an h3 that has the
class of title, as well as the class of blog post
title. And then we can just repeat the title here.
And under here, what we are going to do
is say that we want a div and this div
is going to have a class of Article data.
And then we will have three spans as we did
before, the middle one is going to have the class
of spacer. I can't even remember what I call
this. So let me just quickly double check.
So we had let's quickly find ID and
one of the article series or data.
So article data spacer, that's what we call it. So
let's use it here. And then here, we can just add.
And then this is going to
be the estimated read time.
So that's going to be the base for that. So
still, within this blog post data, we need to
also have an image. And this image is going to be
underneath of this article data div. So for that,
we will use an image and this image is going
to be found inside of the assets folder,
images folder. And then featured featured one. So
let's see how that looks. It looks good so far.
And let me just make sure that
I have this one correct as well.
So let's go all the way back to the
top header. Section Header offset.
And there we go. Now it's under. So let me
close the sidebar now. And we can continue.
So this one is going to be for this one. Let's
go underneath. And in here we want to have an
inner container because we want to limit this
even further when we're on larger screens.
So we will have a class of
container here applied to a div
and inside of this div we are going
to have a p tag, some dummy text
and then we can just read pita underneath.
Let me just add some separation here so that
the text is more readable, then
we are going to have a blockquote,
which is going to be this. And for this,
we can just use the blockquote element.
And let's apply a class of quote.
In here, I'm going to have a p tag.
And then I'm going to have a span,
this ban is going to have an icon inside of it,
which is going to be for the quotation marks.
So this icon is going to have
a class of Ri double quotes
L. So let's take a look at that. And
now we see the icon showing up here.
Then, after this span closing tag, we are
going to add some additional text. In effect,
we don't really want a lot. So what
I'll do is just copy a portion of this,
let's say about here, and then pasted in here.
And then we can just repeat the same thing
with the span, so that we get the closing
quotation mark. So the only difference here is
that we have to change the icon here so that it's
facing the left. In this one, we can just change
it from L to R, or write, just like so. And then
we just repeat the same p tag that we have here,
underneath. And now we can go ahead and add the
card itself. So this card is going to be inside
in order div is going to be inside in order
div is going to be inside an outer div.
And we are going to call this one author.
And then we will make it a grid container.
In here, we are going to have a div and this div
is going to have the class of author image box.
Inside of it, we will have an image. And
this image is going to have the class of
Article image. And we can find it inside of
the assets folder, images folder. And then
it's going to be the author that jpg. So let's
scroll down here. Now we can see the image.
And then we can go underneath of this author
image box div. And now we will have another
div that has the class author about and then
here, we will just have a description of the
author including the name and so on. So it will
be an h3 that has the class of author name.
Then we can use John Doe here, then we will have
a p tag. This p tag is going to have some dummy
text as well. Let me make this smaller. And under
the p tag, we will have the social media icons.
And in fact, something that we can do is just
borrow it from here. Since it will be basically
the same thing. And then we can just paste it
here. Let me see how many did we have we had
Instagram, Facebook and Twitter. So
I guess we don't need the last one.
And yeah, that's pretty much everything that
we need for the markup as far as the blog post.
So now let's go inside of the CSS file and
styled up this page. So we will begin here
by selecting the blog post. And I'm
going to give this a padding bottom
of five run. Then I'm going to select the block
post data and I'm going to give this a display
of flex. Then box direction column. And
then I want to align items to the center.
I'm going to do the same thing for the text
align And then I'm going to apply a padding block
of 2.5 round. And then I'm going
to select the blog post title.
And here, what I want to do is add responsive
typography. So I'm going to set the font size,
and then I'm going to use clamp. So here,
what I'll do is specify a minimum font size,
then in here, I want to set a font size that is
going to adjust based on the viewport width. So
in this situation, I'm going to do five B W. And
then this right here is going to be the maximum
size. So for example, if we
go ahead and test that out,
let me just make sure that
I grabbed the right handle.
And even then I still wasn't able to grab
it, notice how this the size of the font
is growing. And once it gets to that six
RAM, it just stops growing all together.
So that's the way that you
can set responsive typography.
Underneath, what I'm going to
do is select the blog post data.
And then I'm selecting the article data that's
inside of it. And this will have a margin bottom
margin bottom, which is going to be 2.5. Rem,
then I'm going to select the blog post data image
the width here is going to be 100%. The height is
going to be the item min height as some and then
object fit cover. We also want
to set an object position here.
And it will be center 10% Just like so then
I'm going to select the blog posts container.
And then the container that is
inside of it. So this would be
this container that we have here
inside of this blog post container.
In here, I'm going to set a max
width, this max width is going to be
90 REM. So that's as large as it will get, then
I'm going to get rid of the padding that we have
by default on the container class. And then
this will be a display of flex, display,
flex. And then here we want to change
the flex direction back to column.
And then we are going to apply a gap which
is going to be the gap variable that we have.
And that's just going to basically add
some spacing between all of our items,
as you can see here. So the next thing
that I want to do is style up the quote
the quote is going to have a background
color, which is going to be the secondary
background color. And it will also it will
also have a padding all around of 2.5 REM.
Then underneath, I'm going
to select the quote paragraph
and I'm going to set the font style to italic.
Then I'm going to select the quote span.
And this will have a font size of five rent.
So that's going to make the quotes here larger.
And I should be selecting the span I just like
so. Although that's actually pretty large. Let me
make it smaller. Let's do something like half it's
actually too small. So let's do 3.5 And that's
better. So now I'm going to select the author
element, or the element with the class of author
and I'm going to apply a margin top of five
rem and then a gap which is going to be
the gap variable that we already have
then we can go ahead and add a background color,
which is going to be the
secondary background color.
Let me just scroll down so that we can
see what's going on. And what we can't
see much of it right now because of the
large image. So let's switch that out
author image box. And all we have to do
here is just give it a position of vertiv.
So if we scroll up, now, we still can't see it.
But we're going to be fixing that shortly. Now
the height is going to be item min height as some,
just like so. Then I'm going to select the
author about in this we'll have a padding
all around of 1.5 REM, then display
will be a flex and flex direction here
will be column. And then in here,
I'm going to apply a gap of one REM
for separation between the content that we
have here. Now I'll select the author name.
And this will have a color, which is going
to be the light color followed by font weight
of 400. The next thing that I'm going to
select is going to be the author paragraph.
In this will have a max width of 50
RAM and a margin bottom of one run.
Finally, we are going to
select the author, social media
so author about and then the social
media element that is inside of it.
Just scroll down a little bit more. And here,
what we want to do is set the margin top
to auto. And what this will do is that when
we have a lot more room towards the bottom,
this social media container is going to move as
far as I can to the bottom without touching this.
And then I'm also going to get rid of the margin
bottom that we have here by setting it to zero.
So now comes the fun part. This is
where we make the website responsive.
So under the media queries, we will do
iMedia and then screen and we do min width
followed by the breakpoint that I'm going
to be using which is going to be 700 pixels.
Then here, what I want to do is
target the trending news box.
And let's go back to the main page so that we
can see what's going on. I'm also going to go
ahead and make this smaller back to 100%. Just
so that it's easier to show the breakpoints.
So this is going to be for the trending
news box which is this one right here.
And what I'm going to do here is
change the flex direction to row.
Then what I'll do here is add
a line items to the center.
And we still can't see it because
we're not at the 700 breakpoint.
But there we are. Then I'm going to select the
trending news image box in this will get a width
of 50%. So now things are going to fit better.
Now I'm going to select the trending news data
in the margin here is going to be set to auto.
So now this will move towards the middle.
text align here will be center as well. Then
I'm going to select the newsletter description.
So let me scroll back down to the newsletter
right here. So news letter description
and the max width here is going to be set to
40 Rum. And then with the form container, inner
I'm going to set an align items
here of center, just like so. Then
for the popular tags, while the popular tags
actually come before this, let me just move up
with the popular tags container,
as well as the footer container.
What I'll do here is just change the layout. So
now we're going to have sets side by side. So
what I'll do is say grid template columns, I want
to use the repeat function. And then I want to
specify how many times I want this repeated.
So I want to two times and it's going to be one
fraction each. So now you can see that they're
both side by side. Then, or the company data.
Which is this right here, I'm going to change
the order back to the first one, so zero,
and that's going to place it over here instead.
Then if we go back to the block Posts page, here,
I'm going to select the author. And I'm going to
set a grid template columns here. So the first
side is going to be 25. Rem, that's decide for the
image. And then the other one is going to be one
fraction, so as much space as it can. And that's
going to give us a better layout. And notice how
the margin auto down here is coming into play
by pushing it all the way to the to the bottom.
So let's now work on the second breakpoint.
Let me just grab this, paste it underneath.
And then I can just go ahead and close this.
So the second breakpoint is going to be
for tablets. So I'm going
to change this one to 768.
And when it comes to choosing your breakpoints,
all you have to do is just go on to a responsive
view. So let me just make this bigger. So for
example, you go on the responsive view. And then
all you have to do is just use the handle
to stretch the viewport here and just kind
of figure out where the layout breaks. And
then that's going to allow you to choose a
breakpoint where you can correct that issue that
you're currently having with the layout breaking.
So let me quickly close that. And let's go
back to working on the second breakpoint.
So let's go back to the main page. And
this is going to be for the featured
content. So featured content. And here,
I want to set a grid template columns.
So I want this to be repeated four
times, and then one fraction each.
Then what I want to do is specify some
grid, template rows and row template rows.
Here, I want to say that the first one is
going to be five RAM. So that's going to be
for this banner. Then the other ones, I'm going to
repeat them four times one fraction each as well.
Don't worry still looks messed up. But
it's going to make a lot more sense
soon. So let me just make this bigger.
So that I have a chance to open up the
responsive view here. And then if we go here and
take a look at the grid. And what we can do now is
basically position the elements where we want
them to go. So as far as the headline banner,
what I'll do here is set a grid
column. And then I want to say start
at one, so that's going to be the first line and
stretch all the way across here to negative six.
So for this, we can just do negative one. And
now notice how the layout is correcting itself.
And this let me just remove this so that it's more
visible. Now the banner is stretching all across.
Then what I'll do is stretch it further
down. So I'm going to set a grid row.
And then I'm going to tell it start actually not a
grid row. I'm going to be doing that on the other
ones. Not this one. What I want to set here is
a font size which is going to be the font size
So now I'm going to select the featured article.
And this one is going to have a grid column,
it will start at three, and then stretch
all the way to the end, just like so.
Then for the grid row, I'm going to say start
a line number two, and finished a number four.
Then I'm going to select the featured article
number one, this is me selecting them individually
should be number one. And then
here, I'm going to set a grid column
telling it to start at one
end finish at three, like so.
Let me copy this, paste it underneath. And
now I'm going to change this to number two.
And for number two, well actually, for number
two, we don't need it. Because number two,
it's already sharing the styles that we just
applied to every single featured article here.
However, the one that we do need is number three.
And this one is going to start at number one,
and then stretch all across to the end.
Just like we did here with the banner,
then what I want to do is tell it to start on the
grid row at four, and finish at six. Just like
so. And notice how we went from a boring layout to
this really nice looking layout that we have now.
So we can close this for now. And the next thing
that I want to do is target the older posts.
So here, older posts, and
then the article inside of it.
And here I can say grid template columns,
the first 125 rem and the rest one fr
so now we get a similar card as to what we had for
the blog post. With the author card that we have
done underneath, I'm going to select the older
Post article image wrapper. And the height is
going to be set to auto. The next thing that I'm
going to do is target the blog post data image
in here, what I want to do is
change the height from SM, to MD
just like so. And let's not forget to close this
so that it works. And now you see that it does.
And that's going to be it for this breakpoint.
Now we move on to the third breakpoint. So again,
as we did before, let me just copy this one.
So we don't we don't have to type it again
is the down here. And all we have to do now is
change the breakpoints. So here we do, and 24
and then here we are going to reset the menu.
So I'm going to change the position to initial
then the width to initial as well.
Padding, initial background color
transparent and then the opacity initial. And
then we will do the same thing for the transform.
So the next thing that I'm going to do
is target the list that is a direct child
of the menu element. And here the flex
direction will be changed back to row.
So now we have to hide these two
buttons for the sign in and sign up
since we are in the desktop screens now. And to do
that, all we have to do is say green, LG hidden.
And now we can say display none and it's gone.
So now what we have to do is show the other two
buttons that we had on the side. So if I make this
smaller here, these two buttons To do that, we
just select the opposite class that we had for
this, which was screen at some hidden. And then we
do a display of block, like so. So the only thing
we have to do here is style display and to make
it look like the fancy buttons that we had before.
And to do so first, I'm going to select the sign
up BTN. And this will now get a padding all around
of point, or REM. And now the background is going
to show up, we still have to animate this button
on hover. So for that, we are going to be creating
a keyframe animation. So we will do add keyframe
and then the name. Here, I'm going to call
this animate border. And then we usually
have a starting position, and then an ending
position. So you can say, from like zero,
than anything in between to 100%, or any amount,
to be honest. But here, I'm just going to do
two, which is basically going to be the ending
position. Because you can have from basically
saying start here, and then two. And here. So
to what I want to animate here is the transform,
Translate X, then negative 50%. And that's pretty
much it. So all we have to do now is just add
this animation on hover. So here, I'm going to
select the btn that has the class a fancy border.
And I'm going to say that on hover, I want to
target there'll be four pseudo element. And then
here I set the animation property, then followed
by the name of the keyframe animation, which is
going to be animate border, I'll say, over point
75 seconds, the animation is going to be linear,
and it will be infinite. So if we go ahead
and test that out, well, it's not working.
Let's see if we can find the issue. So
here select any btn that has the class
of fancy border on hover. And then we target the
before pseudo element and apply the animation.
So let me just go ahead and try this by
itself. Oh, by the way, the reason why I do the
btn is because I want the effect
to only Well, it's working there.
But yeah, I was saying that I only want this
effect to apply to this button. And not this right
here. Because if you remember correctly, this also
has the fancy border class. So that tells me that
the issue comes from the BTN. So let's go back
inside of the index to HTML, make this larger.
And if we scroll down here, find the button. Well
here we can see that I have BTT as opposed to BTN.
So I'm assuming I have the same mistake here
as well. And yes, we do. So let's correct that.
And now we can just go ahead and close all of this
since we are only going to be working within the
CSS file now. So let's make this smaller.
And now if we go ahead and test that out,
this doesn't work, which is exactly
what we want. But this should not work
and it does. So moving on. The next thing that I
want to select is the featured articles container.
In here, what I want to do is apply
a grid template columns, one fraction
and then 40 rim which is going to be for the side.
So now they're going to be side by side here.
Then what I want to do is select
the trending news image box
and this is going to get a width of
10 REM a height of 10 REM as well.
And then what I want to do is
select the popular text container
right here. And what I want to do in there is
set another The grid template columns, repeat
three times one fraction each. Then for the
next one, this is going to be for the footer
container. So I guess we can just copy this,
paste it down below. And this one, we can just
change the name to butter container. And this
one is going to be repeated five times instead.
Just like so, now we have to correct us because
obviously it doesn't look right at all. So since
we are now spanning five, what I can do here
is target the company data, company data.
And what I can say is that the grid column, I want
it to spin by two, because we have four items.
So let me just comment that out. No. So let me
just comment that out for now. So here we have
four items. But now we are basically saying
that we want this repeated five times.
So we don't have enough room to fill every single
one. So it just stays like that. So what we
do here is just ban this one by two. So now it
makes up for the space that we have here empty.
And it just looks a lot better. As you can see.
Now I'm going to select the company description
in this is going to have a max width of 85%. So
it's just going to stretch out a little bit more.
Now for the copyright notice. Here,
I'm going to give this a margin top,
a bottle, and it's going to push
the text all the way to the bottom.
Finally, I'm going to select the blog post data
image. So let's go back to the blog post page
to blog post data, and then the image inside of
it. And the height here is going to be 40 Run
like so. Now we can go ahead and
move over to the next breakpoint.
And this breakpoint is going to be at 1200 pixels.
And what I want to do here is very simple, I
just want to modify the older post grid wrapper,
which is this one right here. Since now we have
plenty of room, what we can do is say older posts.
Grid wrapper, grid template columns. And then I
want to repeat this two times one fraction each.
So if we go ahead and make this bigger you'll
see that now we get the layout that we want.
Then what I want to do is add another
breakpoint. And this one is going to be
at 15 1300 pixels. And then I
only want to focus here on the
featured article. And what I'm going
to do here, so featured article
is set the grid template column to start at three
and stretch all the way to the end. Obviously,
we're not going to see any changes there
because we are not in a large enough view.
But if you made it bigger, now you can see it
well you can't see it because it'd be a messed up,
we have to correct it. And to do so what we have
to do is select featured article number one, and
then I can say here grid column one, end at three.
And then for the grid row, we can say start at two
and as you can see here, now this portion is
a lot larger and stretches all the way towards
the bottom. Now let's just make sure that
everything still works. So looks good so far.
This as well change the theme. Local Storage still
works. And while there's an issue here, as you can
see, it's not changing to the appropriate color
because if we went back to the original project,
this should be blending in with the same color
as the navigation for the head. and everything
else we have here. So let's go ahead and
go back inside of Visual Studio code.
And since this is related to the light
theme, all we have to do is just come here.
And while this is the issue right here,
this should be the light color instead.
So light, and this one should be dark.
So let's go ahead and take a look at that. And it
works. But we still don't have the right color.
As you can see. And that's because this
one should be the same as this one.
So now we should work. Well, it's still broken,
because once the switches to the black color,
the title should be white. So let's take a
look at the hover effect for the article.
Which should be somewhere around here.
Oh, that's because I did not add it in. So
article. On hover, we want to target the
article title. And what we want to do here is
just change the color to be the transparent.
Was it the light color? No,
actually, it was the hover
light color. So let's go ahead and test that
out. And as you can see, now everything works
perfectly and everything else still looks
good. So let's check out the responsiveness.
So right here, this is the mobile
view, the navigation still works.
This as well. If we scroll down, everything
still looks good. Let me check out the Swiper.
And let's now adjust the viewport
width and everything's still
scaling properly. And yeah, it looks like we are
done. So if you guys enjoyed this video tutorial,
make sure to show me some love. And if
you have any questions, leave them in the
comments down below and hopefully I can
clarify any doubts that you might have.
Feel free to also check out the completed files
just in case you run into issues as I mentioned
at the beginning, so that you can fix them a
lot faster and not have to wait for a response.
Other than that, I'll catch
you guys in the next one.